[Music]
so while the media spent Tuesday finding
new ways to say how Biden will
eviscerate Trump they missed actual news
the host of the first debate include
Rachel Maddow yay
on the bright side it could have been
John Brennan and Joy Behar and said we
get the duchess of smirk talk about
taking the moderate out of the moderator
rachel's to the left of marx and I don't
mean the brothers or Richard now she's
totally capable but she's also totally
biased her livelihood depends on it and
after she spent two years Hawking a
fantasy that painted the president as a
Russian stooge you think the dams would
think twice about letting her near the
stage in case you forgot here's some of
her best work this guy alumina keeps
turning up again and again
Constantine eliminate Constantine
connect Constantine kalimba Constantine
eliminate he's still Russian military
intelligence Tillamook a short man who
goes by costia this guy Constantine
Columbia aluminum smelters is sleeping
at his smelter sabotage in his smelters
came to his smelters Alex vanderzwaan
Alex vanderzwaan Alex vendors want
premium atomic number 24 chromium plant
in Kazakhstan chromium plant in
Kazakhstan next time you see something
chrome-plated take a deep breath cough
it out and think of the Trump Soho big
story tick tick tick tick tick boom
started ticking again
tick tick tick tick tick tick tick tick
four hours later he starts tick tick
ticking again the obvious point is what
if Fox News had pulled this stunt and
picked a highly opinionated moderator
sadly diamond and silk were busy huh but
we assume our media pals would get wind
of it but strange that's not the case
here it's odd how little a ripple this
made in the media pond instead they just
pushed absurd hallucinations a lot of
people are talking about now is that if
he loses Trump he won't go I absolutely
think he will not leave how deranged do
you have to be not just it to believe
that but to actually say it out loud the
derangement blinds you so much that you
forget it's your side trying to undo an
election it's not Trump resisting the
vote or the voters but the left
concocting ways to seize power
or that doesn't require elections but I
get it it's been a rough two years for
the media the country is doing great and
that's bad if your industry is built on
bad news the only thing they have going
for them an active imagination
too bad the public's learn to ignore it
all right Katie it's a brain they knew
they could make this brazing choice
because they knew no one would call him
on it right yeah I mean the idea that
they will pick Rachel Maddow but won't
do a Fox News debate with moderators who
are in the news business really is
astounding to me Rachel Maddow is
basically a conspiracy theorist if you
look back at all the Russia coverage
that she did that she claimed was
factual let's question what she actually
got right very very little of it she sat
there when lawrence O'Donnell who's on
after her said that maybe President
Trump responded to Syria and that the
Syrians launched a chemical weapons
attack to distract away from the Russia
issue I mean that's a pretty serious
conspiratorial charge to make and this
is all about the double standard right
conservative media conservatives are
never allowed to ask the questions
whenever they get a question at the
White House press briefing or during a
press conference they're berated by the
press is not real journalists capable of
asking questions but Rachel Maddow can
moderate a debate this is you know what
standard yeah and the one you know we at
Fox we have our commentators and we have
but we label everything when you go to
the Fox News fridge you know what you're
getting you know what I mean you know
you have your straight vodka have your
vodka and soda
what are you correct I don't know what I
am I'm a kumquat juice I have no idea
squeeze a lot of kumquats what's kind of
hurt I would say generally you know
we've had people who have opinions as
debate moderators but I think this is
sort of egregious and I'll tell you why
I think we try to abide here at Fox that
there's a line between people who are
opinion right people who are new some
people criticize they oh they but look
I've seen this line and I think the
public is best served when it's not
blurred I've seen this here I've seen it
the Washington Post of the Washington
Post I was both a reporter
and the net Ettore writer and when i was
a reporter the editorial people didn't
tell me what to do when i was an
editorial writer i never even talked to
the journalist so it seems to me that as
someone who's done a debate for fox it
would I can't believe that see that
MSNBC is doing this and I think to pick
up on what you were saying I'm surprised
that the Democratic Party isn't saying
hey we don't like it because it then
opens the door to conservatives doing
the same thing down the line
exactly and that's opens the door for
Jesse Watters it's probably it's
probably in her contract though to
moderate these debates and NBC didn't
want to cause any problems with their
biggest political star they already have
enough problems or getting sued for a
quarter of a billion dollars by the
Covington boys they spiked that
Weinstein expose you know things didn't
work out with megyn kelly they didn't
work out with Brian Williams it didn't
work out with Matt Lauer so there's a
lot of problems over there they don't
need this they have a lot invested in
Rachel but her brand has suffered
because she lied for two years and so
they need to realign her brand with the
NBC news division to resuscitate her
credibility now because even the New
York Times reporters aren't allowed on
her show because she's too fringe hmm
but what do you make all of this Kennedy
well I look at this and I think if I'm
an independent or Democrat voter and I'm
looking at this field I wouldn't hear
from them and I want to hear how they
take each other on how they present
their ideas and if they can do something
other than attack the president which
Rachel Maddow can't do that and so the
biggest worry for voters like that if
she's going to insert herself too much
into these debates when really you know
these stages both of them are going to
be incredibly crowded and you have to be
very precise and how you extract
information and the questions you ask so
the candidates have to think and you
know Lord knows that I don't know that
she's capable of asking a really tough
follow-up question and you saw
Charlemagne and Elizabeth Warren it
takes one follow-up question to
completely trip up a candidate and I
think it's really important when you've
got such a crowded field yeah and
they're not good and she's not going to
ask questions that the that will pull
anybody to the
it'll just be how liberal can you get
which candidates does she like best is
she going to go easier on them and
that's also a disservice to people watch
I actually don't mind her asking the
questions I mind that there's a double
standard about who gets to ask the
questions I think that people are
capable of reporting and also having
opinions but this idea that only the
left is allowed and the far left is
allowed to ask the questions
legitimately that's where it gets
ridiculous like if Rachel Maddow is
capable of asking questions so is Jesse
Watters if she can ask Liz Warren about
her fake Indian heritage probably not I
probably don't think so
and she's headless born on her show
about three times I think more than any
other Democrat presidential candidate
she's been on the Rachel Maddow Show a
lot so it's pretty clear you know
there's a rooting interest there this is
an outrage by the way I bill Mars a
smart guy how can you believe that that
a president would say I'm not leaving I
mean I just like the most insidious say
in the course of the last like 2016 that
he would he's not going to necessarily
abide by the results
Bill Maher has lost it he used to be
funny he used to be relevant but he's
acting as though the president has
already been defeated we haven't had the
election yet and we have a lot of run-up
between now and then so stop acting like
he's barricaded himself inside the Oval
Office with a water pistol and Michael
Cohen's carcass